It's great to be joined today by Tara Isabella
Burton, who is the author of Strange Rights
New Religions for a Godless World and the
Novel Social Creature.
Tara, it's so great to have you on.
Oh, thank you so much for having me. I'm delighted
to be here.
So many of us and many in my audience have
seen the studies that show that adherence
to organized religion and identification as
as religious and as members of individual
religions have declined in the United States.
But there is another sort of side to this,
which is the idea of spirituality, which can
take a lot of different forms. And you talk
about ways in which while sort of more traditional
religiosity is being rejected, that we're
not necessarily seeing a decrease in this
broader umbrella of spirituality. Can you
talk about how spirituality is different than
religiosity and maybe give us some examples
of where we're seeing it? Sure.
So just for a little bit of background, like
as you say, about a quarter of Americans identify
as religiously unaffiliated. Often they call
the Enno any nones. That number goes up to
36 percent of Americans born after 1985. So
we're talking about a huge proportion of particularly
millennial and younger population. However,
that doesn't mean, as you say, that they're
not interested in spirituality and spirituality,
at least as as I understand it. And as I work
on it and my book is about sort of various
elements of religious life, unbundled, you
might say, divorced from organized religion,
which which is itself about so much more than
just personal belief, organized religion,
and indeed any religion, you might say, has
sort of a component that is belief and dogma,
a search for meaning, individual purpose,
but also community understanding of a kind
of social place and the rituals that kind
of bind that community together. And what
we're seeing isn't necessarily is that spirituality
is somehow different from organized religion
and offering those different things. But often
that we find people, young Americans, particular,
more willing to find these different components
of religious life from a variety of sources.
Someone might, for example, still go to like
Christmas and Easter services or various high
holy days with their families a couple of
times a year, have a sense of community from
a hobby that they do also practice meditation
or yoga kind of privately and really just
creating their own religion rather than sort
of adopting wholesale the model of an existing
organized tradition.
So what's the difference between some of what
you describe and just a lifestyle in the sense
that I mean, one could imagine that one finds,
for example, veganism, yoga and bicycling
to be sort of related to the values that they
exhibit and dealing with the problems they
most acutely identify as needing solutions
or whatever. How do we how would we distinguish
that from whether it is a lifestyle, whether
it has a sort of spiritualistic component,
whether it is more religious? What are the
lines? Or maybe it's a gray area.
So I actually think it is a gray area. I think
it's almost impossible to actually have a
working definition of religion. You see this
actually in other areas where people are often
sort of talking about cults. What makes a
cult versus a quote unquote, normal religion?
The lines are blurry. Sometimes I joke. It's
like porn. You know what, when you see it.
But the same time, even within sort of academic
definitions of religion, like there are as
many definitions of religion as there are
scholars of religion. In my book, I talk about
sort of Durkheim or Clifford Giertz, all of
whom see religion as completely different.
It's about belief. No, it's about society.
No, it's about symbols and sort of a shared
understanding. All of these things are also
true more broadly. So I think a useful way
to think about it is not kind of is this a
religion, is it not a religion? But looking
at the ways in which organized religions have
traditionally been kind of transmission vectors
or places for a lot of the components of religious
life all at once, you know, your your sense
of meaning, your sense of purpose, your sense
of community and your sense of ritual largely
coming from one place. This was all the more
true when, for example, where you worshiped
on Sunday or any other day of the week, for
that matter, would also be where you met people.
You were most likely to perhaps form a relationship
and marry and have children with a community
that sort of supported you through your various
life stages, your values, your sense of ritual,
your sense of meaning and purpose were tied
up. And I say your as or traditionally in
America more broadly like. Sort of this the
stereotype of the 1950s where what church
you went to was a sort of byword for a whole
other host of social associations. And that's
really what we've lost in the quote unquote,
spiritual, but not religious or secular age
rather than belief or interest in the metaphysical
or the divine.
Well, thinking earlier than the 1950s, in
earlier human history, there was a time which
I find very interesting, where a membership
in a religious group actually conferred an
evolutionary advantage in the sense that you
were far more likely if you got along with
the people around you than if you didn't to
survive and to have enough food to eat and
to go on to have children and procreate and
pass on your genes. That element of religion
has dramatically diminished. Certainly, we
could probably find some places in the world
where it exists, but but in modern Western
world that that's not a factor. I'm interested
in whether you you see this sort of modern
lifestyle slash spirituality vector's having
some component of that advantage in society,
maybe not literally to our survival, but to
some degree of prospering maybe. Yes.
I mean, yes and no. And what I mean by that
is simultaneously, I think that the kind of
new tribalism that we've formed through various
affiliations, often by as distinct from religions
and to which we were often born, are determined
by choice. You know, we are part of this group
or that group. Our interest in cross fit to
toe or what have you. Gives us a sort of family
we choose in a very particular way. At the
same time, though, I think that so much of
the way in which the sort of contemporary
spirituality works is through a quite individualized
model. We basically each make our own religion
in that way. And I say we sort of more broadly,
but. Particularly, young Americans tend to
be more likely to mix and match even. And
this isn't exclusive to people who call themselves
religious nuns. There was a 2013 Pew study
that found that about. 30 percent of self-identified
Christians also said, like, I believe in reincarnations.
About a similar number said they believe in
psychics, astrology, things that are not traditionally
understood within the Orthodox Christian umbrella.
We're seeing more broadly a willingness on
the part of both the religious, traditionally
religious and the unaffiliated to kind of
create through through choice, through what
they buy, the classes they take. It's often
a very sort consumerist choice, their own
sort of spiritual identity, especially any
Internet based capitalist world such as we
are in. That often means voting with your
dollars kind of consuming as a form of creating.
Do you buy the Sephora, which kit, which has
its starter pack of tarot cards, which was
for a while available on kind of the high
street until it was actually withdrawn over
a bit of controversy? Do you spend your money
on a yoga class or meditation app? And I think
the way in which we've become sort of more
atomized, more individual in part because
of this sort of obsession with our own choices,
our own affinities, has made perhaps this
iteration of spirituality a little bit less
group focused. I would say, than religion
is traditionally understood.
Well, one of the interesting things that you
mentioned gets into some of the examples that
relate to one of the characteristics that's
often present in certainly the more devout
areas of the traditional religions is that
there is not a very strong sort of error correcting
mechanism the way science has where questioning
the beliefs and changing the beliefs is is
welcomed. A lot of times the community leader
in more established religious religions doesn't
welcome people coming in and saying, I think
that you're actually wrong about this, that
the other thing and saying, hey, we made a
mistake, let's change what the what the scriptures
are. That's often not encouraged. And so when
I look at some of the modern ways in which
we might explore spirituality or religion,
I sort of pay attention to that. And so, for
example, I had an experience with the followers
of this gentleman named Jordan Peterson a
couple of years ago, where there were a lot
of examples of when I would critique something
he said or did. There was a sort of post hoc
rationalization of your misunderstand you.
You have to be misunderstanding what he said
and therefore your critique is not accurate.
Or another example might be either flat earth
or astrology, where you might try to say,
hey, let's try to apply some critical thinking.
And the idea of revising the dogma as it may
be, is not at all welcomed. Is that the case
in a lot of these spirituality outlets that
you look at? Not in a lot.
How present is that? It's present. But I'd
say a slightly different form, which is to
say often these groups, or rather that these
practices as instantiated in individuals have
come up in part because they're sort of we
have such a profound public distrust now in
institutions. There is a sort of, you know,
particularly religious institutions from sex
abuse scandals to the political alliance of
particularly white evangelical Christianity,
with the GOP to say nothing of sort of the
broader failures of institutions we see, whether
it's sort of the sense of the media or politics
or what have you. There is, I would argue,
a widespread sense that because institutions
have failed, we can no longer trust them.
What do you do when you can't trust the institution,
when you can't trust science, or you think
you can't trust science or journalists or
the establishment? You turn it inwards. There's
a sense in which it is sort of similarly,
perhaps it is. I do want to say anti intellectual.
Perhaps that's too strong, but I'm intuitional.
There are a lot of these movements from wellness
culture to to an extent, even some of the
followers of Jordan, Peter said in a certain
way, although he is the sort of leader which
adds a different dimension. But the idea that
you focus, you turn inward, you further focus
on yourself, which is what you can control
and what you can rely on. And I think that
that you often find that in a lot of the conspiracy
theorists and even the way that a lot of like
Jordan Peterson fans will sort of talk about
him versus the sort of the P.C. establishment
that's hiding troops from you. There is a
very much an anti-establishment A.I. institutional
strain to a lot of these beliefs. And so I
think on the one hand, there is a rejection
of kind of dogma in the abstract as something
that institutions do that we don't want to
sort of succumb to. And yet there is also
a resistance to, for example, in the case
of like wellness culture, you know, very few
of the scientific facts on Gwyneth Paltrow
website Goop are we might say they are not
always fact checked to the fullest extent.
And indeed, they, I think, gotten quite a
bit of trouble over that. But I think the
narrative goes something like, well, like
this feels true and it's completely understandable
that when a person might think that none of
the authorities around them are worth listening
to, they can't rely on them suddenly to feel
like going with your gut. There are worse
things you can do.
I'm interested in talking a little bit about
the protests we've seen over the last couple
of weeks, protests that I widely support the
objectives of and in which I'm sympathetic
to. I've seen some examples. I don't have,
you know, feel the need to say this is a lot
or not a lot. But I've seen examples of would
seem almost like pseudo religious types of
moments where black people in large groups
are I'm sorry, white people in large groups
apologize to black people for their privilege
or calls for white people to give the black
people at the protests money in some kind
of symbolic reparations that things that things
that to me start to feel a little bit cult
and that they go beyond sort of the activism
component to it. How should we be applying
this religiosity, the spirituality analysis
to the movement we're seeing take hold over
the last couple of weeks?
Sure. I think speaking more broadly about
the social justice movement, as I do in the
book, I mean, I think it's absolutely right
to apply this scholar of religions lens or
the religious lens to it. And I think that
when people often do that, sort of it's often
a charge that was leveled against the social
justice movement. The right. You know, they're
zealots. They're a religion. They're a cult,
et cetera. I'd like to sort of brought say
that do something a bit more complicated,
which is that, yes, it is religious in nature.
That is both. As with any any movement, the
good and the bad it which is to say, I think
the sense of hope, the sense of profundity,
the sense that this is meaningful, that there
is a a better world at the end of all of this,
which is, you know, quite striking, I think
in our somewhat somewhat alienated capitalist
world. One might say there aren't that many
places for not just the sacred or enchantment,
but a vision of that enchantment that is linked
up with a vision of the world hard's that
should be. Things like wellness culture are
very individualistic. As I've said, you know,
you great. You can you can achieve a sort
of enlightenment soul cycle, but it begins
and ends with you. And I think that it's absolutely
right to talk about the kind of the symbolism,
the sense of catharsis, the collective effervescence
as a Durkheim might say that you might find
at a protest movement as being religious in
nature. But I think that's why it's that's
what I would say. That's why it's been so
successful, so widespread precisely because
it is able to harness a kind of religious
longing. This is not just a group of people
protesting. It is people sort of getting in
touch with perhaps not a divine purpose, but
a sort of fundamentally real purpose to change
the world, to make it better or certainly
a purpose that's bigger than them. Yes, absolutely.
Absolutely. And I think it brings it both
brings people together, which especially after
a however many months of isolation, I think
is all the more appealing. And it provides
a framework to kind of see an. A world that
could very well see meaningless and chaotic,
some form not just of meaning in the abstract,
but but purpose. What one person's individual
life, individual choices to. To protest, to
get involved. How that might link up with
a kind of grander cosmic bigger than them
scale. So I think it's absolutely right to
think about it in terms of religion, but also
sort of the question to ask. It's not like
are they a religion? And therefore, should
it be sort of discounted as a rational but
rather as a religion? What is this offering
that other forms of living in 2020 aren't
necessarily offering? No. How what why is
this so meaningful and compelling?
Very, very interesting.
We've been speaking with Tara, Izabella Burton,
who's author of Strange writes New Religions
for a Godless World and also author of the
novel Social Creature.
Tara, so great having you on. I really appreciate
it. Thank you so much. It was lovely.